[Music]
okay guys so like a lot of women I wear
makeup most days but especially on the
days where I have to film for work so it
got me thinking while I'm getting my
makeup done what exactly am I putting on
my face and how safe is it I decided to
do a bit of research it turns out that
the average American woman uses twelve
products every day exposing herself to
about a hundred and twenty six unique
chemicals many women use even more than
that and a lot of those chemicals are
considered toxic they've been linked to
cancer infertility birth defects they
can even mess with your hormones but the
industry is largely unregulated by the
FDA which cannot require cosmetics
companies to prove a product is safe
before it goes to market it also can't
recall a product once it's found to be
dangerous for consumers it's up to the
company to do that so why are these
products even allowed to be sold to us
there are over 10,000 chemicals used to
formulate cosmetics and personal care
products and these are industrial
chemicals that we're talking about I
mean the same chemicals that are used to
grease gears or sterilized surgical
equipment or stabilized plastics are
used in your everyday makeup and
personal care products Jenna told me
that while the European Union has banned
more than 1300 dangerous chemicals from
their cosmetics and personal care
products the US has only banned eleven
you know oftentimes people opt for the
more expensive lines like Chanel or
Kevin a kwon over drugstore options
thinking perhaps maybe they're better
and by virtue of being better maybe
safer is that necessarily the case no no
I mean it really isn't it's so
counterintuitive in that regard just
because you're buying a more expensive
product it doesn't mean that it's safer
look for labels that that have fewer
ingredients stay away from the word
fragrance and a product that simple word
fragrance can hide
dozens and dozens of unsafe toxic
chemicals
Genet also told me about a handful of
other chemicals I should be wary of
foundation can contain heavy metals like
arsenic and titanium
which can cause cancer when it's inhaled
eyeshadow can contain formaldehyde and
mineral oils that are derived from crude
oil eyeliner can contain heavy metals
like lead and arsenic that are linked to
cancer and reproductive harm blush can
contain parabens that mess with your
hormones and talc which can have
asbestos mascara can contain
formaldehyde and dyes like carbon black
also cause cancer and up to 3/4 of
lipstick tested by the FDA contained
lead many also contain preservatives
like DHA which is linked to cancer and
reproductive harm and that's only makeup
harmful chemicals can be found in all
sorts of body products like lotions and
shampoos too
it's a lot to take in thankfully
consumers can search for the health
ratings of tons of products on databases
like skin deep pink dirty and good
guide.com
but unless we demand more regulation of
the cosmetics industry choosing safe and
healthy products may continue to be a
guessing game
[Music]